scientists have probed the universe for
signs of life beyond Earth for years and
now recent discoveries strongly suggest
that alien life could in fact exist
earlier this year NASA made a
groundbreaking announcement that liquid
water exists on Mars today in fact
scientists estimate that at least one
fifth of Mars was covered in oceans
about four-and-a-half billion years ago
this means that both fossilized and
living organisms could be on the planet
but water isn't exclusive to Mars
scientists have confirmed a massive
global ocean on Saturn's moon Enceladus
beneath it's icy outer shell and
chemicals found in the water suggest
that this ocean floor is lined with
hydrothermal vents the same vents that
may have spawned life on Earth and
Jupiter's moon Europa could Harbor more
water than Earth itself brownish veins
on the surface point to seeping liquid
water from the moon's mantle and both
America and Europe have invested
hundreds of millions of dollars in space
missions to explore this further
Saturn's largest moon Titan is the only
other body in our solar system with
lakes on the surface but these lakes are
made of liquid methane not water and
while water is essential to the
formation of life as we know it
scientists have shown how methane based
oxygen free living cells might exist on
Titan in addition to water Comet and
asteroid impacts are considered key to
the formation of life impacts cause
amino acids to combine and form the
building blocks of life and there could
be comets in other planetary systems
that are doing this right now in fact
the Milky Way may not be the most
hospitable galaxy for life according to
a scientific study other galaxies could
host 10,000 times more habitable planets
than the Milky Way one planet that
scientists have discovered in our own
galaxy is being dubbed
earth 2.0 kepler 452b
an earth-like planet 1,400 light-years
away
and its size orbit Sun and age provide
the opportunity for life to arise
somewhere on the surface should all the
necessary ingredients and conditions for
life on the planet exist according to
NASA's John Jenkins and kepler 452b
is not the only place scientists are
looking for life they are using the
Allen telescope array to determine if an
alien civilization lives in an unusual
star system 1,500 light-years away
though chances are very low large hunks
of matter orbiting star could be part of
an alien built mega structure known as a
Dyson swarm with so many scientific
discoveries that point to
extraterrestrial life many believe the
question shouldn't be is there life
beyond Earth but rather will we ever
find it